bonjour je m'appelle Alexis alti j'ai 22
ans j'abite à sainttistisane et je
cherche une formation en alternance dans
le domaine de l'infographie pour moi
l'infographie c'est un petit peu jouer
avec des programmes les manipuler dans
tous les sens et créer des produits et
des éléments qui vont avec je sais
utiliser un tout petit peu les
programmes peu importe le le ce que je
veux faire c'est l'infographie j'ai
d'autres passions que l'infographie tel
que le théâtre j'ai fait du théâtre un
moment donné j'ai fait aussi de
l'équitation je suis véhiculé j'ai j'ai
un véhicule je suis pointilleux et
motivé et vous ne regretterez pas de me
faire
confiance contactez-nous sur notre page
facebook
www.facebook.com/974 TV ou par téléphone
0262 92
974 CV votre émission au service de
l'emploi à la
Réunion